الصور التي اظهرها الامريكيون واعتقد كان
لديهم غيرها كان بالامكان ان تظهر وكانها
من اطلاق الصواريخ والصور التي لدينا
والماخوذه من زاويه اخرى اظهرت انها تتعلق
بمنشاه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم واقدم اليكم حلقه جديده من
برنامجكم الذاكره السياسيه نتابع في سلسله
هذه الحلقات مع ميشيل اليومري السياسيه
والوزيره الفرنسيه السابقه فاهلا بك معنا
مجددا على شاشه العربيه معالي الوزيره
[موسيقى]
السابقه كانت وهي وان الاداره الامريكيه
انا كذبت بهذا الموضوع
كلها التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده ولكن
كل ما قدمته الولايات المتحده علنا كان
يستنده في شكل كبير الى وقائع غير صحيحه
واعتقد ان كولن باول الذي كان وزير خارجيه
وقتها اقر بذلك لاحقا عندما خيته لانني
سافرت ايضا الى الولايات المتحده لاشرح
الموقف الفرنسي ولم يكن الامر دائما سهلا
ولكن مع ذلك ذهبت الى هناك
لم يكن موافقا تماما او لنقل لم يكن يتبنى
موقف الرئيس عندما التقيته واكذلك التقيت
كونداليزا رايس وقتها وقلت لها انتبه انما
تقومون به خطا العراق بلد تعددي صحيح ان
موقعه مهم ولكن هناك مواقف مختلفه وقد
نخاطر بخلق من طاقه غير مستقره
النبي
لاحقا فقالت لي
اكون على خطا تماما في تحليلك للوضع كان
ذلك بعد الحرب بوقتا طويل ولكنه كان
اقرارا مهما وصحيح ان جاك شيراك كان لديه
الكثير من الاهتمام لهذه المنطقه من
العالم لانه كان يجد ان هناك الكثير من
النقاط المشتركه التي نتقاسمها فهو كان
لديه علاقات شخصيه مع بعض القاده في دول
الخليج ولكنه ايضا كان يحرص على اعتماد
سياسه تجمع بين دفاع عن حقوق الانسان التي
هي في صميم قناعاته ولكن كان ايضا يحرص
على احترام الثقافات وسيادته الدول
رئيس
في عام 2005 ما كانت اجواء القياده ان ذاك
على ثور سماع نبا الاغتيال بخصوص الجهه
الفاعله
همم
ما اريد قوله ان هذا الاختياله كان له
واقع كبير جدا في العالم السياسي ولكن
ايضا في مجمل المجتمع الفرنسي لان علاقتنا
مع لبنان قديمه ووثيقه جدا وهناك بيننا
تعاطف لدرجه اننا نشعر وكاننا من اسره
واحده
والحرير علاقه صداقه وعلاقه عائليه بينهما
وكان شغال يرى ان الحريري يلعب دورا مهما
في اعاده اعمار بلده بعد الحرب مستفيدا من
تجربته ناجحه في السعوديه وكان شراك يرى
ان الحريري هو عنصر استقرار في المنطقه
وكان شغال متفقا تماما مع الحرير عندما
سعى الاخير الى استعاده سياده لبنان
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه من كوريا وكان شيراك
مقتنعا منذ البدايه ان اغتيال الحريري كان
من تدبير حزب الله ومن خلفه سوريا شيراك
تاثر شخصيا لانه فقد صديقا وكان غاضبا جدا
مما حدث ومن الناحيه السياسيه هذا كان
عنصر زعزعه في هذه المنطقه هل اتت المحكمه
الخاصه بلبنان اكلها باعتقادك وانتم
دافعون اساسيون باتجاه تاسيسها لانه
التقرير الاول لدكتور مجلس اشار الى
مسؤولين سوريين ثم لم نلحظ ذلك لاحقا بقيه
الاتهامات فقط لحزب الله لم يكن ذلك قصورا
في تحقيق العداله باعتقادك كما ارتات
المحكمه او كما تاء التقرير الاول على
الاقل
لقيت سميد
اعتقد ان المحكمه خضعت لضغوط قويه جدا هذه
ضغوط اثرت على صيغه القرار النهائي
للمحكمه جاكشي غاك تحرك كثيرا لتقوم
المحكمه بواجباتها طوال اجراءات المحاكمات
ولكن حدثت ضغوط كثيره وهو ما ادى الى صدور
مختلفين عن المحكمه
المسؤولين السوريين وانت تحملين الاثنين
او كما اعتقدت القياده الفرنسيه
ممن ورد ذكرهم في تقرير المحكمه الاول
ولكن لماذا
انا
الاغتيال هو جريمه وان اغتيال شخص مثل
رئيس الحريري او رئيس الحكومه الحريري
يشكل جريمه
اذا ما كان العالم مقتنعا فعلا ولديه
معلومات بانهم تورطوا في الاغتيال
الاسماء ولهذا السبب العلاقات مع سوريا
معقده الى هذا الحد تحديدا من اراد ان
يحمي النظام السوري القيادات على الاقل
التي تورط الشيطان
اعتقد انه النظام نفسه
اذا النظام السوري بحدته هو يضغط على جهاد
دوليه لكي تشطب اسماء بعض قياداتها
المتورطه
حدث ذلك ولكن من البديه عندما نرى
الاجراءات والصعوبات التي ترافقت حتى صدور
قرار المحكمه مورثه ضغوط ممن لم اكن هناك
ولم اكن عضوا في هيئه المحكمه لاقول ذلك
ولكن حدث الضغوط من اجل التخفيف من قرار
المحكمه النهائيه على اي حال هذه هي
قناعتي الراسخه في جميع الاحوال
على الكثير من المعلومات والتقارير
والتحليلات الهامه التي طلعتي عليها هل
كان امر كهذا ليصدقني
نور التي تعرفونها وانظروا كيف تطورت
الامور قناعاتي ان ضغوطا مرست كي لا تظهر
نسبيا الا امورا عاديه
باعتقادك وقنعتك الراسخه ولكن
بالطبع بدون شك لم يلصق الامر به فقط ولكن
مع النظام السوري
الحلقه معالي الوزيره شكرا لوجودك معنا
مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام فاصل قصير قبل ان
يتابعنا لدينا في هذه الحلقه من الذاكره
السياسيه مع ميشيل ليومري السياسيه
والوزيره الفرنسيه
عملته مع رئيسين للجمهوريه
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث قال ان تركيا
على مفترق طرق بين قارتين وكان يريد ان
يدفع تركيا في اتجاه القيم الاوروبيه بدلا
من ان تتجه شرقا اما نيكولا ساكوزي فكان
يقول ان تركيا هي بلد كبيره وقيامها
مختلفه عن قيامنا
احييكم مع مجددا متابعينا الكرام اينما
كنتم نتابع في هذه الحلقه من الذاكره
السياسيه مع السياسيه والوزيره الفرنسيه
السابقه ميشيلا ليومري اهلا بك معنا
والكثير من الملفات والمواضيع الشيقه
نتابع فيها معك الان مع الوزيره موضوعنا
الاخير في هذه الحلقات معالي الوزيره
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو يعني مهم جدا وعملت
كثيرا عن كثب في ملفاته في عملك السياسي
هل تسطرين للتاريخ بان الاتحاد الاوروبي
نجح كفكره وكومشروع وكتيفيد ام انه فشل
اكثر مما نجاح
اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي نجح في تحقيق
بعض الاهداف فهو استطاع ان يصنع من
الاتحاد الاوروبي وحيده من اكبر
الاقتصادات في العالم الاتحاد الاوروبي
ناجح حتى الاشهر الاخيره في ان يجعل من
اوروبا وح فلما في وقت كانت القاره مقسمه
بالحروب طوال الاف الاعوام اعتقد ان
الاتحاد نجح في تسهيل علاقات التبادل بين
دول الاوروبيه عندما تكون في برلين او
مدريد في روما او بروكسل تستخدم العمله
ذاتها وهذا يشكل تقدما كبيرا وطلاب
يتابعون جزءا من دراستهم في بلد اخر ولكن
الطريقه لا تزال طويله وانا عملت مع جاك
جاك في مجال الدفاع الاوروبي ولا اتحدث عن
الجيش الاوروبي هذا امر مختلف اعتقد ان
جيوش ستبقى وطنيه لفتره طويله لاننا عندما
نرسل جنود لتنفيذ مهمات في الخارج مع وجود
مخاطر على حياتهم فعل الدوله التي ينتمون
اليها ان تتخذ بنفسها قرار ارسالها اذ لا
يمكن اتخاذ القرار من قبل هيئه اخرى
خارجيه اما الدفاع الاوروبي فهذا ممكن
ويجب العمل كثيرا من اجل التوصل الى نمط
حياه مشترك حتى الان الحمايه الاجتماعيه
لا تزال مختلفه في باريس عما هي عليه في
وارسو وعلى المواطنين الاوروبيين ان يشعر
بانهم ينتمون الى وطن واحد ينبغي العمل في
مجالات مختلفه حتى في المؤسسات الرسميه ما
استطيع قوله ان الاتحاد الاوروبي حقق
نجاحات في بعض المجالات وهي كانت ضروريه
للعالم ويبقى الكثير مما يجب العمل من
اجله علينا ان نستمر في العمل من اجل
تحسين الاداء في الاتحاد الاوروبي حيث نرى
اليوم ان تجمعات المهمه هي الصين والهند
امريكا الجنوبيه وليس فقط الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اي مجموعات اقليميه ان
لم يزيد عدد سكانها على الخ ياتي مليون
نسمه من يكون لهذا التجمع اهميه اقتصاديه
وسياسيه اضافه الى ذلك ان لاوروبا صوتا
تحدثنا في بدايه هذا اللقاء عن الاستقطاب
الثنائي والتعارض بين الولايات المتحده
والصين حاليا الخطر يكمن في ان تنضم باقي
دول العالم الى هذا القطب او ذلك وقتها
ستحدث مواجهه انا اجد انه على الاتحاد
الاوروبي دور يقوم بها على غرار ما قام به
شارل ديغول في خمسينيات القرن الفائت
عندما قال ليس هذا هو الحل الحل يكمن في
ايجاد طريق ثلاث على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يجمع كل تلك البلدان التي لا تريد
المواجهه تلك البلدان التي لا تقف مع
الولايات المتحده في صوره كامله ولا مع
الصين في صوره كامله انما لديهم كلمتهم
ووجودهم ومصالحهم
خاصه التي يدافعون عنها لهذه الاسباب انا
اؤمن بالاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن لا يزال
امامنا الكثير لنقوم به
الجيش الاوروبي الم يكن فشلا بانه لم ينشا
نو
بي
كلا اعتقد ان علينا
الامام وفي نهايه المطاف الحرب في
اوكرانيا ان كانت فيها نقطه ايجابيه فهي
انها دفعت البلدان الاوروبيه الى التفكير
حتى وان كانت تعيش بسلام ان عليها
الاستعداد لاي اعتداء محتمل الدول
الاوروبيه التي كانت في غالبيتها لا
تنفقوا الا مبالغ محدوده جدا على الدفاع
باتت اليوم تبذل جهدا كبيرا من اجل زياده
امكاناتها العسكريه ماذا ذكرته في ندوه
قبل ايام ان الاوكرانيين من دون دعم
المعدات الاوروبيه والامريكيه لم استطاعوا
ان يصمدوا في وجه الجيش الروسي ولو توافرت
المعدات من دون وجود عزيمه الاوكرانيين
على صمود لما كانت المعدات تنفع في شيء
على القاره الاوروبيه اليوم ان تستخلص
العبر كلها واعتقد انه بات من الضروري
اليوم وعلى غرار ما تقوم به دول عده
القيام بتعزيز وسائل الدفاع وايجاد اليه
لاستخدام المعدات المشتركه كما انتجنا
طائره ام 400 لتزويد الوقود ومروحيه النمر
ومروحيه ان ايج 90 وهذا يدفعنا الى بذل
مزيدا من التعاون في المجال الصناعي في
تلك الندوه ذكرت هيئات الاركان في جيوش
والوزراء انه علينا زياده الانفاق ولكن
ليس لشراء المعدات العسكريه من الامريكيين
بحيث نصبح معتمدين عليها علينا ان نطور
صناعاتنا العسكريه لتلبيه حاجاتنا ولكي
تساعدنا على تجهيز جيوش اخرى انا اعتقد
بضروره ايجاد دفاع اوروبيا وليس جيشا
اوروبيا قبل 30 او 40 عاما دفاعا اوروبيا
يمكن تشكيله في الاشهر المقبله وليس جيشا
اوروبيا انا فكرت في هذا الامر عندما كنت
وزيره لدفاع وشكلنا مجموعات من وحدات خاصه
يمكنها ان تتدخل سريعا قمنا بمناورات
تدريب مشتركه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وانشانا
مصانع مشتركه وانشطه مشتركه من خلال فرقه
او شيئا من هذا القبيل يجب تعزيز القدرات
هذا بالامكان تحقيقه بسرعه نسبيا وهذا
يتيح لاوروبا ان يكون لديها دبلوماسيه
فاعله اعتقدوا انه لا توجد ديبلوماسيه من
دون دفاع من دون ذلك نبقى في اطار الكلام
نعلن عن نوايا حسنا ولكن ان لم يكن لدينا
مثلا الامكانات للدفاع عن حقوق الانسان او
لمساعده بلد صديق لدفاع عن سيادته من خلال
امكاناتنا وباستخدام قوتنا ذاتيه انا ذاك
هذا الامر لن يكون مفيدا علينا ان نكون
قادرين على ان ما فعليا الدفاع وتاليا ان
ادعو الى تحقيق ذلك ويمكننا ان نتقدم في
هذا المجال النقطه الاخيره في الملف
الاخير تركيا الم يعتبر عدم ضم تركيا فشلا
وهل كان لعامل الدين دور في منع هذا
الانضمام
[موسيقى]
كان مع انضمام تركيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
حيث قال ان تركيا على مفترق طرق بين
قارتين وكان يريد ان يدفع تركيا في اتجاه
القيم الاوروبيه بدلا من ان تتجه شرقا اما
نيكولا ساكوزي فكان يقول ان تركيا هي بلد
كبيره وقيامها مختلفه عن قيامنا وصحيح ان
موقف الرئيس اردوغان كان عاملا مهما لهذا
الرفض لان تركيا تدعو الى نمط حياه يتعارض
مع ذلك السائد في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اجراءات الانضمام كانت بدات وقد حدث تقدم
في بعض المجالات ولكن في الوقت ذاته كان
هناك رفض مطلق للعيش على غرار ما يعيشه
مجمل الاوروبيين انطلاقا من هنا
الموقف الثالث الذي يعمل على التوفيق بين
الاثنين يقول ان تركيا لا يمكنها حاليا ان
تتبنى الموقف السياسي الاوروبي في المقابل
يمكن ابرام اتفاقات معها في المجال
الاقتصادي وحتى الاجتماعيه وهذا الامر
ممكن
بامتياز عريض اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات التي قدمتها لنا من تاريخك
السياسي ولا اعرف اذا كان يمكن السؤال عن
المستقبل بالنسبه اليك سياسيا اذا كنت
تتطلعين بعد الى مناصب عليا في الدوله
شوفوا لي دي مواجهه
همم
كما سبق وقلت لكم انا لم اطلب ابدا اي
منصب اقترحوا علي مناصب عده وكان لي الحظ
انها كانت مثيره حاليا ابتعدت قليلا عن
السياسه الداخليه الفرنسيه واحاول تقريبا
وجهات النظر بين الدول لتفادي حدوث نزاعات
هذا ما اقوم به من خلال عدد من الجمعيات
ومراكز الابحاث في المانيا او بريطانيا او
فرنسا اقدموا محاضرات في مختلف بلدان
العالم من اجل التكلم عن كل هذا وبعدها
نرى ما سيكون مثيرا في المستقبل فنحن لسنا
قادرين دائما على توقع المستقبل
معالي الوزيره في حلقات الذاكره السياسيه
وهمم شكرا حبت صدرك ولي وقتك الثمين شكرا
وبالعربيه ايضا شكرا لك مشاهدينا الكرام
شكرا جزيلا لكم ايضا انتم للمتابعه
ومتابعينا على بودكاست شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعتكم هذه الحلقات من الذاكره
السياسيه والملتقانا يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل
مع شخصيه جديده وذاكره سياسيه جديده ف الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]